and we're here to give out superlatives
to each other for most likely drew
[Music]
most likely to be caught taking selfies
just said
i don't even take a selfie i shake
i don't i don't take a selfie you do not
see me take a shelf yes i do i saw the
video of you in the neighborhood going
all around oh what
have a good day everybody yes or twice
or twice come on but i don't take a lot
of that's more than me
more than me
[Music]
most likely to casually mention the most
mind-blowing story from the past
nick well i do like to shock people yeah
and he does have a past and he loves to
give every
excruciating detail
no i don't you do too i don't give
enough
that's right
virgin then
virgin now most likely to know current
pop culture trivia i would say just say
yeah i would say jose as well me
re-ready
re-read read for rihanna re-read re-read
i think it's true because jesse is
addicted to tick-tock yeah
but that's only dr pimple-popper
most likely to end an argument between
everyone before it gets started
bob
that'd be me yeah i'm the peacemaker
he's daddy
chloe's boss a daddy for daddy's
that's how old i am
[Laughter]
you're a great granddaddy the firstborn
most likely to be good at technology
bill bill
yeah kind of i mean i i just got a cell
phone last december but i do know
photoshop and all that kind of stuff so
you're pretty up on that stuff yeah i'm
not verified so i'm certified registered
and verified i mean i still haven't
mastered you know
the word
that's wrong
oh my god i tried
most likely to do the most during drag
that would be jesse
and everyone was so calm and then here
comes just say like this bigger than
life and he just loves being a blonde
but they didn't like why can he strut
well thank you guys oh you're welcome
baby most likely to be swiping through
dating apps during an important
conversation
i mean just say even when we're doing a
shoot there's jesse down there trying to
play with his phone and make it look
real look what
oh he's always on the phone excuse me i
have to take this call
okay that's drama i'm happily gay
for 67 years how many hours a day do you
spend on your phone
um probably uh six
how many but not last couple because i
lost my phone on the freeway in l.a
i put it on the roof of the car after
singing gig and forgot to take it off
sunday so i get it when i'm head back
home yeah it's somewhere on the 210
freeway
and he is going through withdrawals
most likely to be hip on modern slang
this one
[Music]
you
okay folks those are our superlatives
thank you drew for having us on and you
can follow us at tick tock facebook
instagram and grindr youtube thank you
drew thanks drew thank you for having us
on the superlatives see you soon
tata rose queens come on can you cup
your cup your hand right yeah like
you're a light bulb like you're holding
a light bulb
you